she is the friend that everybody
deserves I don't know a better person
Oprah Winfrey and Gayle King are taking
friendship goals to new heights with a
glamorous girls trip
this says Oprah Winfrey to make the
besties traveled to Paris together with
Gelles daughter Kirby bumpass to attend
a friend's destination wedding after the
ceremony
Oprah convinced the trio to keep the
party going so when in Paris you must
dance in front of the Eiffel Tower
[Music]
Gayle shared this pick of the ladies
rocking elegant evening wear and joked
in the caption quote just three girls
heading to Shake Shack in Paris then on
to friends dance party clearly our
friend has great taste in destination
parties of course Oprah and Gayle
stepped out in their very best for the
occasion mama Oh turned heads in a green
floral frock and polished up too while
the CBS this morning host looked like a
golden goddess in a one-shoulder gown
with simple makeup well this is one of
many trips where the gal pals have
glammed it up and now Oprah and Gayle
are planning an adventure where we all
get a cruise the duo announced the
getaway back in June we are planning a
girls getaway and we want you all to
come along with us yes so you bring your
best friend with you whoever that is
your mom you're on your sister your
daughter your bestie from elementary
school bring your Gayle I say bring your
Oprah we're getting the high seas on
January 30th 2019 you can book your
tickets now to sail with us at Holland
America calm
you